UH one of Donald Trump's main selling
points to clueless voters was talking
about how he would fix trade and he
would he would make it so that trade was
better for American workers and
partially he was going to do that by
getting the United States out of NAFTA
the North American Free Trade Agreement
this is a major campaign promise and it
worked
um insofar as a lot of Trump supporters
didn't really understand anything about
trade free trade protectionism NAFTA
they just jumped in full speed ahead
with the idea that NAFTA just flat-out
needs to go lacking basically any
understanding of what the implications
of that would actually be unfortunately
or fortunately the pet depending on how
you look at it this is quickly becoming
yet another broken campaign promise
Donald Trump is not going to be pulling
the United States out of NAFTA yesterday
Donald Trump told the leaders of Canada
and Mexico that he was not going to end
the North American Free Trade Agreement
the White House said that Trump quote
agreed not to terminate NAFTA at this
time and the leaders agreed to proceed
swiftly according to their required
internal procedures to enable the
renegotiation of the NAFTA deal to
benefit all three countries of course
Donald Trump had to try to salvage this
as not yet another broken campaign
promise so he tweeted that if
negotiations don't go well then he'll
terminate NAFTA basically what happened
is what happens with most issues that
Trump doesn't really understand like
Obamacare right
who knew that health care was so
complicated uh hey listen I got on the
phone with Justin Trudeau and the the
the Mexican president and after ten
minutes I realized NASA is actually very
complicated very very complicated folks
nobody knew that nobody could have
predicted that other than many
Republicans and many Democrats Senator
John McCain Republican from Arizona
urged Donald Trump not to pull the u.s.
out of NAFTA saying it will devastate
the economy in my state I hope he
doesn't do that and there's lots of red
herrings in the NAFTA and trade stuff
from the
campaign uh nonpartisan Congressional
Research found in 2015 that NAFTA is not
responsible for the exodus of jobs south
of the border
nor for a big jobs boom in the u.s.
researchers have basically concluded
that NAFTA has had a minor impact on the
US economy so it's a red herring in two
senses number one it was a red herring
during the campaign and that people who
didn't even really understand it thought
that it was a great reason to vote for
Donald Trump because I guess they
believed he was going to do something
about it but the second layer of the red
herring is that any serious nonpartisan
analysis has indicated that it actually
has not had a significant effect one way
or the other on the American economy and
I got a I got an email from a viewer
saying David you know what happened
Trump realized his businesses stand to
lose money if he actually pulls us out
of NAFTA so it stays campaign promises
be damned I don't know if that's the
case I only am not sure about that what
I know is that Trump got on the phone
with what I guess we would consider the
adults of North American leadership the
Prime Minister of Canada and the
president of Mexico and they were
talking and Trump learned things many
things as Donald Trump likes to say and
he's no longer going to fulfill that
campaign promise the Trump fists can
rationalize this as a victory no matter
what they can rationalize anything as a
victory if Trump had yesterday
terminated NAFTA gotten the u.s. out of
NASA they'd say look he did it he's a
truth teller he did what he said he was
going to do instead now they can say hey
listen Trump's a heavy hitter negotiator
he's willing to revise his views on
what's good for the American economy he
got on the phone with the Canadian Prime
Minister and the Mexican president and
he told them we're renegotiating or
we're out
and they agreed yeah no but no matter
what Trump is we'll be able to
rationalize this